Let's learn English with the
newest Disney Pixar hit film
Soul. And if you're new here every week we
make fun lessons with your favorite movies,
series, music and so much more. So that you can
learn to understand fast speaking natives without
getting lost, without missing the jokes
and without subtitles. Just like Astrid,
who says that our lessons are helping
her to master American pronunciation.
So we'll help you to achieve
your learning English goals too.
It's really simple just hit that Subscribe
Button and the Bell down below to join us.
So in the following clip from
Soul, Joe received some news.
Watch it and then answer in the comments how
would you explain his reaction to that news.
By the way, we've seen a couple
examples already in this lesson
of fast native speech. Now, do you get frustrated
when you speak like this and you can't understand?
If you're like most learners that I know, I'm
sure that your answer was an emphatic yes.
Well I'm here to tell you that it
does not have to be frustrating,
that's exactly why we created our Masterclass
to help you master the 3 Keys to understanding
natives at any speed. Which are vocabulary,
pronunciation and cultural context. It's
absolutely FREE, so I highly recommend that you
give it a try, so that you can take a step closer
to reaching your dreams of understanding English
as well as you understand your native language.
Just go up here or down
description below to get started.
So we still have one more clip to learn
with, but I have a quick question:
do you love Disney movies like this one?
Then next you should check out this playlist
where you will find a bunch of other lessons
with Disney movies that you will adore.
You can find that by clicking up here
or down in the description below.
Okay, so now you're going to
test everything you learned today
by watching all the clips a final time without
subtitles and answering some quiz questions.
But before you go I wanted to remind
you that we make three lessons
every week to help you understand natives
and get confident English fluency.
So the fastest way to do this
is by not missing a single one,
so remember to hit that Subscribe Button
and the Bell below if you haven't yet.